Rossy, you're going to take us through a Rossipe.
It's a Rossipe, tada!
(audience applauds)
And I'm gonna make you something inspired by my dad,
used to make all the time.
Really?
He called it the Hash, Gosh, Darn.
Whatever was in the gosh darn fridge was going in the hash.
So let's get started.
Okay.
(audience applauds)
Put a little oil in your pan.
Oil in the pan.
We are making a delicious hash dish.
So we're gonna take potatoes.
These are just frozen hash browns, right?
That you have in the freezer.
My favorite.
I know you have some in the freezer.
So we're gonna put these in the pan
with a little salt, some pepper.
The thing about hash like this, is there are no rules,
it's really what you have left in the refrigerator.
And it's a great way to use some vegetables
that maybe you had as a side dish a couple of nights ago,
or that are about to go bad.
Yes.
Because the best way
to save money in the kitchen is to not waste anything.
And I believe that this recipe would retail
in total at about $10 and below.
Absolutely, think about potatoes.
(audience applauds)
Yep.
They're a dollar something a pound
and they stretch everything out.
They stretch out my butt.
(Ross laughs)
I'll tell you that much.
A little won't kill you.
All right, let's talk about
what we're throwing in here, Drew.
I have some things from my refrigerator,
like the other night, I roasted some sweet potatoes.
They're going in.
Boom, go in.
Sweet potatoes.
I had some leftover broccoli and carrots.
Those are going in.
Oh, broccoli, oh broccol-I.
What about, you know,
you make some sauteed peppers and onions
and you have those left over in the little Tupperware thing?
I like mine with a little sausage.
Yep, those are going in too.
All right.
We just keep stirring.
We are gonna take some fresh spinach
and throw those in there as well, Drew.
And then, you know, I was thinking about
what's in your refrigerator all the time,
and just to prove that there's no rules
when it comes to hash, you can do anything,
what if you had some leftover macaroni and cheese, Drew,
(audience exclaims)
in your refrigerator?
Throw it in, let's go.
(audience laughs)
No,
into the hash, now, come on.
Into the hash.
Okay.
So we have another pan over here.
Just let that sit there on warm.
Put some oil in this pan over here,
because what we're gonna do
is we're going to fry an egg
to put on top of this when it's all done.
(audience gasp)
Right? Oh, I know.
I love frying an egg.
I think so to,
it gives me "good morning" kind of vibe, right?
Mm-hm.
Salt and pepper your egg.
And then I like to just take a spoon with some of this oil
and just sort of put it over the yolk.
It just helps it cook.
So we have our hash over here, right?
All the elements have come together.
Our egg is cooking, but what about this?
If we wanna take our hash to the very next level,
do you ever look in the fridge
and see some herbs that are about to go bad?
Yes.
What do you do with that?
I hate wasting that money.
Well, let's go to our blender.
Over here, I have some parsley,
some cilantro, some chives.
Sage, thyme and rosemary?
None of that, no.
Just cilantro, parsley, chives, scallions.
We're gonna put them in our blender.
I'm gonna squeeze some lemon into this, Drew.
Lemon going in.
Well, did it come?
Oh, here it is.
Okay, Yeah, ooh.
(audience laughs)
Where is all my juice?
Yeah, no, this one's weird.
Oh!
I didn't realize you were supposed to do that
and it came out like that, I know.
(Drew cackles)
So here's how,
this is how the pilgrims did it.
I just squeeze like this
and hold the seeds in my hand, okay?
We can make it like that.
That's how most sexy chefs do it, Rossy,
so I think you're doing it right.
Okay, put a little bit of red pepper flakes in this.
Some salt and pepper as well, in our herb mixture.
We wanna pour a little oil into this,
a little olive oil as well.
Not too much.
You can always add more, but you can't take it out, okay?
What we're doing here
(mixer whirs)
is we're making-
oh, hi, do your thing girl.
Oh.
(mixer whining)
Yes, I was so into it.
(mixers wind down)
Okay.
This is like a chimichurri situation
and this is done, all right?
I love chimichurri.
Are you ready to assemble?
I am.
Okay, grab your little bowl over there.
Let's take some of our hash
that has the vegetables and the mac and cheese.
Okay, I need a scooper.
Okay, so I have my bowl of hash.
I'm gonna top this with my fried egg, look at that.
and then, ready for this, Drew?
Hold on.
Okay.
She can do it, she can do it, she can do it,
She did it!
(audience cheers and applauds)
Yes, Drew.
Thank you.
Okay.
Now let's take some of our chimichurri sauce.
Just get your spoon in there
And do a little drizz?
And do a little drizz, on top.
Look how pretty this is too, this color.
Beautiful.
Oh yeah, that really does that a nice color.
(audience applauds)
Such acidity to the...
Mm.
Mm, you ready to taste?
I'm ready.
Mm-hm.
Get in there.
Oh yeah.
I'm getting right in there with that yolk.
You can taste how bright that chimichurri is.
The acid in that brings the entire dish to life.
(audience applauds)
And you think about
this was all made with leftovers,
and I have one more tip for you.
This is beautiful.
(audience applauds)
If you have,
If you have extra chimichurri sauce,
you can pour this into an ice tray
and freeze this and then use it later.
What?
You can just, yes.
Break it into your stir fry, next time
you're sauteing chicken, whatever.
Just do the...
This is all stuff that you were gonna throw away.
(audience applauds)
Rossy, that's brilliant.
You can make this Rossipe for under $10 yourself.
Visit thedrewbarrymoreshow.com for the full ingredients.
And as Rossy said, play with what you've got.
(bright theme music)